Jake:哦小彩旗
Jake: Oh, it's the little flag.
Tasha: 就是那个拉条
Tasha: Just that strip.
Katrina: 这个是放哪的
Katrina: Where should this go?
Katrina: 放房间里的吗
Katrina: In the room?
Jake:这个厨房的
Jake: This is for the kitchen.
Jake:厨房柜子下面的应该
Jake: Under the kitchen cabinet, I think.
Tasha: 怎么个事呢
Tasha: What's the deal with this?
Tasha: 居然是这样子贴的好吧
Tasha: So it sticks like this, huh?
Jake:我给你串
Jake: I'll thread it for you.
Tasha: 现在就串吗
Tasha: Thread it now?
Jake:那我干点啥
Jake: What else should I do?
Tasha: 那你串吧
Tasha: Okay, go ahead.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:我回头做PPT呢
Jake: I'll make the PPT later.
Jake:我应该把他的那个卡瑞纳呢
Jake: I should include that Karina thing.
Jake:给他写上去
Jake: Write it in for him.
Jake:这是线啊这啥啊
Jake: Is this a wire or what?
其他人：粘粘呢直接贴起来
Others: Stick it on directly.
Tasha: 我觉得这个不粘吧
Tasha: I don't think it sticks.
Jake:这就是线吗
Jake: Is this a wire?
Tasha: 应该吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Jake:噢对就是破防
Jake: Oh right, it's broken.
Jake:你就被他破防了
Jake: You were just broken by him.
Jake:他去买了个药
Jake: He went to buy medicine.
Jake:然后你拿了药他说他有
Jake: Then you got the medicine, he said he had it.
Jake:就是这样
Jake: Just like that.
其他人：就这样补什么药啊
Others: What medicine are you talking about?
Tasha: 感冒药呀
Tasha: Cold medicine.
Shure: 他怎么还感冒了呢
Shure: How did he catch a cold?
Tasha: 他
Tasha: He...
Shure: 是啊怎么这么脆弱呢
Shure: Yeah, how come he's so weak?
Tasha: 就是呗
Tasha: Exactly.
Jake:有顺序吗
Jake: Is there an order?
Shure: 别传染给我吧
Shure: Don't pass it to me.
Tasha: 不知道呀没有吧
Tasha: I don't know, probably not.
Shure: 你快回学校吧你
Shure: You better head back to school.
Jake:哎哈喽
Jake: Hey, hello.
Jake:哈喽啊
Jake: Hello there.
其他人：你们好
Others: Hello.
Shure: 麦克风拿来了吧
Shure: Did you bring the microphone?
Shure: 伏特加拿的吗
Shure: Did you get the vodka?
Jake:有电有电
Jake: We have power, we have power.
Jake:这边有电
Jake: There's power here.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:哦好嘞
Jake: Oh, alright then.
Shure: 这放二楼吧
Shure: Let's put this on the second floor.
Shure: 到时咱都在二楼
Shure: We'll all be on the second floor later.
Tasha: 怎么样哪个好看
Tasha: How about this one, does it look good?
Shure: 这不是我们宿舍那小推车吗哈哈哈
Shure: Isn't this the little cart from our dorm? Hahaha.
Jake:都都挺好看真的
Jake: They all look good, really.
Jake:第一个好看
Jake: The first one looks good.
Tasha: 你知道这叫心疼小狗吗
Tasha: Do you know what it means to feel sorry for a puppy?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Tasha: 那你好有品味啊呵呵
Tasha: You have such good taste, hehe.
Jake:我这个应该放后头对吧
Jake: Should I put this at the back?
Jake:哎呦卧槽
Jake: Oh, crap.
Tasha: （歌词）五十六个民族五十六朵花
Tasha: (Lyrics) Fifty-six ethnic groups, fifty-six flowers.
Tasha: （歌词）五十六个中华民族是一家
Tasha: (Lyrics) Fifty-six ethnic groups in China are one family.
Jake:一家
Jake: One family.
Tasha: （歌词）噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: (Lyrics) Dun dun dun dun dun.
Tasha: （歌词）嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟
Tasha: (Lyrics) Doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo.
Jake:来串串
Jake: Come on, let's skewer them.
Jake:咱有咱有几个串
Jake: How many skewers do we have?
Jake:咱就一个串
Jake: We have just one skewer.
Tasha: 两个串好
Tasha: Two skewers are better.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:那串一下
Jake: Then let's skewer them.
其他人：今天下午会多来多少人
Others: How many people will come this afternoon?
Jake:不知道
Jake: No idea.
其他人：怎么串
Others: How do we skewer them?
Jake:还有一个
Jake: There's one more.
Jake:就as simple as it is OK
Jake: Just as simple as it is, OK?
其他人： OK
Others: OK.
Tasha: 清华清华生还需要你教吗
Tasha: Do Tsinghua students still need you to teach them?
Tasha: 人家自学
Tasha: They are self-taught.
Tasha: 看看就懂了是吧
Tasha: They understand just by looking, right?
其他人：Zero shot learning
Others: Zero shot learning.
Jake:对Zero shot连Tiss都不要给
Jake: Yeah, Zero shot, don't even need to give a Tiss.
其他人：只需要给我一个东西我就可以对你
Others: Just give me one thing and I can do it.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Jake:就知道你要干什么
Jake: I knew what you were going to do
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
其他人：先做这个认知推理
Others: Let's do this cognitive reasoning first
Tasha: 好今天把面粉给他
Tasha: Okay, give him the flour today
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake:给你推理推理
Jake: Let me give you some reasoning
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：面粉这个可以吗
Tasha: 你觉得可以吗
Tasha: Do you think it's okay?
Jake:呵我你问他可不可以
Jake: Heh, you're asking him if it's okay
其他人：面粉给我就哭
Others: I'll cry if you give me the flour
其他人： 打auto memory了哈哈
Others: It's auto memory now, haha
Tasha: 不用这样子
Tasha: No need to do it like this
Jake:不行要你有
Jake: No, you have to
Tasha: 你有你有点强迫症的
Tasha: You have a bit of OCD
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, I don't
Tasha: 没有没有
Tasha: No, you don't
Tasha: 弄成这样子干嘛
Tasha: Why make it like this?
Jake:就是要弄成这样子
Jake: It has to be like this
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 我看看这个人会不会
Tasha: Let me see if this person can do it
Jake:这人也会的
Jake: This person can do it too
其他人：我不信应该不就应该是这样吗
Others: I don't believe it, shouldn't it be like this?
Tasha: 我不信
Tasha: I don't believe it
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 就是要理这么顺吗
Tasha: Does it have to be so neat?
Jake:对对吧对啊要不然呢
Jake: Yes, right, yeah, otherwise?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Jake:还能拧成麻花嘛对吧
Jake: Otherwise, it would be twisted, right?
Tasha: 搞快点还要做甜品呢
Tasha: Hurry up, we still need to make the dessert
Tasha: 来不及了
Tasha: We're running out of time
Jake:哦哦哦好好好
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay
Tasha: 几点了
Tasha: What time is it?
Tasha: 12点了我靠
Tasha: It's 12 o'clock, damn
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 几点钟几点钟
Tasha: What time is it?
Jake:两点半
Jake: It's 2:30
Tasha: 那个两点半啊
Tasha: That 2:30?
Tasha: 房间还没装饰呢
Tasha: The room isn't decorated yet.
Jake:呃对
Jake: Uh, right.
Jake:房间装好
Jake: Once the room is decorated...
Tasha: 别穿了
Tasha: Stop wearing it.
Jake:走走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 走
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake:呵呵那只剩抖叉叉来穿了
Jake: Haha, then only Jack is left to wear it.
Jake:哈哈加油
Jake: Haha, keep it up.
Tasha: 还要做甜品呢
Tasha: We still need to make desserts.
Jake:对对对来穿一穿吧
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, come on, wear it.
Jake:辛苦你了
Jake: Thanks for your hard work.
其他人：中午吃啥呀
Others: What's for lunch?
Jake:呃还没点呢
Jake: Uh, haven't ordered yet.
其他人：还没点呀
Others: Haven't ordered yet?
其他人：那我建议你
Others: Then I suggest you...
其他人：我饿
Others: I'm hungry.
Jake:我觉得你这个好
Jake: I think your suggestion is good.
Jake:建议来
Jake: Bring on the suggestion.
Tasha: 今天早上的粥吃完了吗
Tasha: Did you finish the porridge from this morning?
Tasha: 先垫垫
Tasha: Have some first.
Jake:对我们还有点油条
Jake: Yeah, we still have some fried dough sticks.
Jake:万一呢我们还有汉堡
Jake: Just in case, we still have some burgers.
Jake:我们还有昨天晚上吃的汉堡
Jake: We still have the burgers from last night.
Jake:有人没吃
Jake: Someone didn't eat.
Jake:两个30多块钱两个
Jake: Two of them, over 30 bucks each.
Jake:最贵的没吃
Jake: The most expensive ones weren't eaten.
其他人：怎么有人没吃
Others: How come someone didn't eat?
Jake:我怎么知道有人没吃
Jake: How would I know someone didn't eat?
Tasha: 就是
Tasha: Exactly.
Jake:你先吃吃你吃不了的你就点
Jake: You eat first, if you can't finish, then order.
Tasha: 哎你干嘛去
Tasha: Hey, where are you going?
Jake:我不是要给你收拾吗
Jake: I was going to clean up for you.
Tasha: 你拿东西了吗
Tasha: Did you take anything?
其他人：怎么你怎么这这让我点了呢
Others: How come you asked me to order?
Jake:那要不你先看看吃
Jake: How about you look first at what to eat?
其他人：吃什么我先看吃什么啊
Others: Look at what to eat first?
Jake:对对对你先
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, you first...
Jake:你先点嘛
Jake: You order first.
Jake:我拿上去
Jake: I'll take it up.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Is that right?
Jake:我还要拿什么上去
Jake: What else do I need to bring up?
Jake:这什么东西
Jake: What's this?
Jake:这个这个我靠
Jake: This, this, oh my god.
Tasha: 这个这个
Tasha: This, this.
Jake:我这个没手拿
Jake: I can't carry this with my hands.
Jake:我拿上去
Jake: I'll bring it up.
Jake:这个有点危险
Jake: This is a bit dangerous.
Tasha: 不然你还想去哪个频道
Tasha: Otherwise, which channel do you want to go to?
Tasha: 不好吃没吃过
Tasha: It's not tasty, haven't tried it.
其他人：没吃过
Others: Haven't tried it.
Tasha: 没有食欲
Tasha: No appetite.
其他人：没吃过所以不知道什么
Others: Haven't tried it, so don't know what it's like.
Tasha: 昨天抹茶
Tasha: Yesterday's matcha.
Tasha: 抹茶蛋挞你吃了吗
Tasha: Did you eat the matcha egg tart?
其他人：坏了
Others: It's gone bad.
Tasha: 坏了
Tasha: It's gone bad.
其他人：不会已经没了吧
Others: It can't be all gone, right?
Tasha: 哼哼
Tasha: Hmm.
其他人：完了
Others: It's over.
Tasha: 无语
Tasha: Speechless.
Tasha: 又是一个不信守承诺的人
Tasha: Another person who doesn't keep promises.
其他人：完了
Others: It's over.
Tasha: 在我心里面
Tasha: In my heart.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：完了
Others: It's over.
Shure: 这真是土耳其的
Shure: This is really from Turkey.
Jake:创作歌手
Jake: A singer-songwriter.
Shure: 你的土耳其
Shure: Your Turkey.
Shure: 我的土耳其
Shure: My Turkey.
Shure: 好像不一样是吧
Shure: Seems different, right?
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Whoa.
Shure: 你这土耳其真的跟我们的很很不一样
Shure: Your Turkey is really very different from ours.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: Jazz版土耳其是吧
Shure: Jazz version of Turkey, right?
Shure: 到时候视频就是
Shure: By the time the video is done.
Shure: 哎我去
Shure: Oh my god.
Tasha: 搞什么这是床被子
Tasha: What is this, a bed cover?
Tasha: 吃破方了已经
Tasha: It's already broken from eating.
Jake:我的线在哪啊
Jake: Where's my cable?
Tasha: 在楼上
Tasha: Upstairs.
Jake:是的在准备
Jake: Yes, I'm preparing.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:在楼上
Jake: Upstairs.
Jake:走走走走走走
Jake: Go, go, go, go, go!
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What are you doing?
Jake:拿线
Jake: Get the cable.
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What are you doing?
Jake:然后插上
Jake: Then plug it in.
Tasha: 然后呢
Tasha: And then?
Jake:然后给你打扫
Jake: Then I'll clean for you.
Jake:我的线在哪啊
Jake: Where's my cable?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:给他印俩眼睛呗
Jake: Draw him two eyes.
Jake:你的线呢
Jake: Where's your cable?
Tasha: 我的线在楼下
Tasha: My cable is downstairs.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 不用充了
Tasha: No need to charge it.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 刚看了
Tasha: I just checked it.
Jake:你的线在哪个楼下
Jake: Which downstairs is your cable?
Tasha: 在椅子上我的
Tasha: On the chair, mine.
Tasha: 你会咬扇子吗
Tasha: Can you bite the fan?
Shure: 来一个
Shure: Give it a try.
Tasha: 哈哈哈能咬能咬能咬
Tasha: Hahaha, I can bite, I can bite, I can bite.
Shure: 能咬吗
Shure: Can you bite it?
Tasha: 展开再咬然后合上的
Tasha: Open it, then bite and close it.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Tasha: 哈哈太美了
Tasha: Haha, it's so beautiful.
Shure: 帅气吗
Shure: Is it handsome?
Shure: 够射吗
Shure: Is it cool enough?
Jake:多多少刚出院
Jake: How long since you got discharged?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, okay, okay, okay.
Jake:出院多久了
Jake: How long have you been discharged?
Jake:我要干什么
Jake: What am I supposed to do?
Tasha: 把被子叠上
Tasha: Fold the blanket.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 行谢谢你
Tasha: Alright, thank you.
Shure: 7天第一次叠叠被子是吧
Shure: First time making the bed in 7 days, huh?
Tasha: 谁7 你天天叠吗
Tasha: Who's 7 days? Do you make it every day?
Shure: 我不点啊
Shure: I don't make it every day.
Tasha: 那不就行了
Tasha: Then it's fine.
Jake:那那也是七天
Jake: But that's still seven days.
Tasha: 把被子放这
Tasha: Put the quilt here.
Tasha: 合上
Tasha: Fold it.
Jake:好合上
Jake: Okay, fold it.
Tasha: 因为我居然发现
Tasha: Because I found out
Tasha: 他又给我发了一床被子
Tasha: He sent me another quilt.
Jake:怕你冻着
Jake: Didn't want you to be cold.
Tasha: 等JoJo my day
Tasha: Wait, JoJo my day.
Tasha: 往那边再放一点
Tasha: Move it a bit more to that side.
Tasha: 黑黑为什么不钉在墙上呢
Tasha: Why not nail it to the wall?
Tasha: 因为他不给钉
Tasha: Because he won't nail it.
Jake:那个小玩意
Jake: That little thing.
Tasha: 哪个
Tasha: Which one?
Jake:那个小玩意
Jake: That little thing.
Tasha: 那个是你要吗
Tasha: Do you want that?
Jake:我不要我要把它放正
Jake: I don't want it, I want to straighten it.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 这样吗
Tasha: Like this?
Jake:他得出来吧
Jake: Should it come out?
Jake:是不
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 是的呢
Tasha: Yes, it should.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 怎么搞怎么办
Tasha: What to do, what to do?
Jake:你做衣服吧要不
Jake: Why don't you make clothes?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 怎么搞你会铺床单吗
Tasha: What to do, can you make the bed?
Jake:这个不够长吧
Jake: This isn't long enough, right?
Tasha: 好像没有到两张床的长度吧
Tasha: It doesn't seem to be the length of two beds, right?
Tasha: 你会不会太过分了
Tasha: Aren't you being a bit too much?
其他人：操你还会这个
Others: Wow, you can even do this?
Tasha: 不得不嫁了是吧已经
Tasha: You have to get married, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
其他人：快了是拦不下了
Others: It's happening soon, no stopping it.
Jake:完了一天求婚80遍我靠
Jake: Oh man, proposing 80 times a day, geez.
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Let's leave it at that.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
其他人：你学的这种琴还是钢琴
Others: Did you learn this kind of instrument or piano?
其他人：钢琴
Others: Piano.
Jake:这个给他套起来吗
Jake: Should we cover this up for him?
Tasha: yes yes
Tasha: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 你会什么乐器吗
Tasha: Do you play any instruments?
Jake:不会
Jake: No.
Tasha: 好我也不会那就好
Tasha: Good, I don't either, that's good.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 已经变了
Tasha: It's already changed.
Tasha: 已经变样了房间
Tasha: The room has already changed.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha: 完了明天还要拆掉
Tasha: Oh no, we have to take it apart tomorrow.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:明天慢慢拆
Jake: We'll take it apart slowly tomorrow.
Tasha: 从哪掏的
Tasha: Where did you get it from?
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This.
其他人：那建议今天你表演
Others: Then I suggest you perform today.
其他人：你快来表演一个
Others: Come on, do a performance.
其他人：匈牙利狂想曲
Others: Hungarian Rhapsody.
Jake:建议你们看看有没有火药杆
Jake: I suggest you check if there's any gunpowder.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：我已经串完了
Others: I've already finished stringing.
其他人：建议你现在点外卖啊
Others: I suggest you order takeout now.
Tasha: 两个串吗
Tasha: Two skewers?
Tasha: 两个串都串完了
Tasha: Both skewers are done.
其他人：哦还得穿
Others: Oh, still need to string.
其他人：没事马上我就去穿
Others: No worries, I'll go string it soon.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:哇那你点
Jake: Wow, then you order.
Jake:你问他们想试什么
Jake: Ask them what they want to try.
其他人：我的评价是元记云饺
Others: My recommendation is Yuan Ji Cloud Dumplings.
Jake:好行那你开吧
Jake: Okay, sure, then you start.
其他人：不如吃拌饭
Others: How about bibimbap?
Tasha: 我也觉得米村拌饭好吃
Tasha: I also think Micun bibimbap is delicious.
Tasha: 搜就知道了
Tasha: Just search and you'll know.
其他人：预制菜预制菜
Others: Pre-made dishes, pre-made dishes.
其他人：那我不要
Others: Then I don't want it.
Tasha: 圆记云饺可难
Tasha: Yuan Ji Cloud Dumplings are difficult.
Jake:别的可是也是预制菜
Jake: But others are also pre-made dishes.
Jake:只是没告诉你自己
Jake: I just didn't tell you.
Tasha: 云记云饺也是预制菜
Tasha: Yunji Yun Dumplings are also pre-made dishes.
其他人：真的吗
Others: Really?
Tasha: 真的
Tasha: Really.
Tasha: 每天小车拉过来的
Tasha: They deliver it by small carts every day.
Jake:那就就吃那个什么叫什么
Jake: Then let's just eat that, what's it called...
Jake:白饭哈哈
Jake: Plain rice, haha.
Tasha: 米村拌饭
Tasha: Rice Village Bibimbap.
Jake:米村拌饭
Jake: Rice Village Bibimbap.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Jake:来
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 您看你一看在家就没套过被子是吧
Tasha: Looks like you've never put on a duvet cover at home, have you?
Jake:套过套过套过
Jake: I have, I have, I have.
Tasha: 套过
Tasha: You have?
Tasha: 套过你跟我说你不知道这样的封起来
Tasha: If you have, then why did you tell me you didn't know how to seal it up like this?
Jake:我知道我知道
Jake: I know, I know.
Tasha: 你知道
Tasha: You know?
Jake:我我可能知道
Jake: I might know.
Jake:我我我这次拨你
Jake: This time, I'll help you.
Tasha: 就是那个10块钱配送费的
Tasha: It's the one with the 10 yuan delivery fee.
Tasha: 就他
Tasha: That one.
Jake:好行
Jake: Okay, got it.
Tasha: 就他一件
Tasha: Just that one item.
Tasha: 怎么办呢
Tasha: What to do?
Jake:好听
Jake: Sounds good.
Jake:牛逼虽然是这是啥呀
Jake: Awesome, though, what is this?
Jake:这哈哈哈
Jake: This, haha.
Jake:这啥呀哦嘿
Jake: What is this? Oh hey.
Jake:行行行自创了是吧
Jake: Okay, okay, you made it yourself, right?
Jake:自创歌曲
Jake: Original song?
Tasha: 我想喝水了
Tasha: I want some water.
Jake:想喝水了
Jake: You want some water?
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:给您倒水
Jake: I'll pour you some water.
Jake:您有杯子吗
Jake: Do you have a cup?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Jake:没杯子
Jake: No cup?
Lucia: 哦这是巴赫的一个小步舞曲是吧
Lucia: Oh, this is a Minuet by Bach, right?
Tasha: 我要充电
Tasha: I need to charge.
Jake:挺好鼓手
Jake: Pretty good drummer.
Jake:咱就干鼓手的事情哈哈哈
Jake: Let's just do drummer stuff, hahaha.
其他人：这谁的这谁的手机
Others: Whose phone is this?
Jake:我的
Jake: Mine.
Tasha: 多了5个菜
Tasha: We have 5 extra dishes.
其他人：就是现在是相当于一人一个菜
Others: So now it's like one dish per person.
其他人：然后98个菜
Others: And then 98 dishes.
其他人：9个人8 哎
Others: 9 people, 8... hey.
其他人：9个 10个人8个菜
Others: 9, 10 people, 8 dishes.
Jake:来给您倒水
Jake: Let me pour you some water.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Shure: eah yeah
Shure: Yeah yeah.
Shure: eah
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: ladies and gentlemen
Shure: Ladies and gentlemen.
Shure: now let's welcome to ego life world
Shure: Now let's welcome to Ego Life World.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
其他人：味太臭了味太臭了
Others: The smell is too bad, too bad.
Shure: today we will have a great and brain party
Shure: Today we will have a great and brain party.
Shure: it's called ego party
Shure: It's called Ego Party.
Jake:要要
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure: （歌词） wanna do and spoon around我的心就像running down
Shure: (Lyrics) Wanna do and spoon around, my heart is just like running down.
Shure: （歌词）冷漠
Shure: (Lyrics) Indifference.
Shure: （歌词）怀着冷暖与嘲笑
Shure: (Lyrics) With coldness and ridicule.
Shure: （歌词）怀着热闹的
Shure: (Lyrics) With hustle and bustle.
Shure: （歌词）天空海阔
Shure: (Lyrics) The sky and the sea are vast.
Shure: （歌词）谅我一生不羁放纵爱自由
Shure: (Lyrics) Forgive me for being unrestrained and loving freedom all my life.
Shure: （歌词）也会怕有一天会跌倒oh no
Shure: (Lyrics) But I'm also afraid that one day I will fall, oh no.
Shure: （歌词）谁人都可以
Shure: (Lyrics) Anyone can.
Alice:太优雅了
Alice: So elegant.
Alice:啊微微你咋样了
Alice: Ah Tasha, how are you?
Tasha: 快了
Tasha: Almost there.
Alice:哇哦好可爱
Alice: Wow, so cute.
Shure: 好OK
Shure: Alright, okay.
Shure: 呀
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 我说句话
Shure: Let me say something.
Shure: 他现在就会有点耶
Shure: He will have a bit of yeah now.
Shure: 哎不对
Shure: Hey, no.
Shure: 不够等一下
Shure: Not enough, wait.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: cowarding scent
Shure: Cowarding scent.
Shure: yeah response in the tab going in
Shure: Yeah, response in the tab going in.
Tasha: 啥
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Shure: （歌词）novembering i feel so lonely
Shure: (lyrics) Novembering, I feel so lonely.
Shure: （歌词）so decided gonna be my soul
Shure: (lyrics) So decided, gonna be my soul.
其他人：修硕你来唱我来弹
Others: Shure, you sing, I'll play.
Shure: 弹什么
Shure: Play what?
Shure: 唱什么
Shure: Sing what?
Alice:你看就是这个房间
Alice: Look, it's this room.
Alice:需要我帮忙吗
Alice: Need my help?
Tasha: 好像快收拾完了都
Tasha: Looks like it's almost done.
Shure: 你在唱什么呀
Shure: What are you singing?
Shure: 我们的志愿者先生
Shure: Our volunteer gentleman.
Shure: so hot
Shure: So hot.
Tasha: 是吗开空调
Tasha: Really? Turn on the AC.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 鱼安康
Tasha: Fish Ankang.
Alice:安康鱼
Alice: Ankang fish.
Alice:康鱼康安
Alice: Kang fish, Kang An.
Shure: 其实那俩字不发音就不就是安康
Shure: Actually, if you don't pronounce those two characters, it's just Ankang.
Shure: 那是鱼字旁
Shure: That's a fish radical.
其他人：这是什么
Others: What is this?
Tasha: 蒸蛋吧
Tasha: Steamed egg, I think.
其他人：谁的
Others: Whose is it?
Tasha: 不知道谁的
Tasha: No idea whose.
Jake:这早早餐早餐早餐早餐
Jake: It's breakfast, breakfast, breakfast, breakfast.
Jake:干啥呢
Jake: What are you doing?
Tasha: 小彩彩穿完了吗
Tasha: Is Xiaocai dressed?
其他人：马上闲着就去穿
Others: Almost, will dress soon when free.
其他人：多问一句就要多讲
Others: Ask one more question, need to speak more.
Jake:那你要不到外面学去
Jake: Then why don't you go learn outside?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Tasha: 不用不用没事
Tasha: No, no, it's fine.
Katrina: 这是在房间的吗
Katrina: Is this in the room?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:穿完了吗
Jake: Are you done dressing?
Tasha: 上楼贴贴上
Tasha: Going upstairs to stick it on.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 好对走
Tasha: Alright, let's go.
Tasha: 嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟
Tasha: Doo doo doo doo doo
Tasha: 变了没
Tasha: Did it change?
Jake:变了
Jake: It changed.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake:这是哪啊
Jake: Where is this?
Jake:吃完之后吃饭
Jake: After eating, let's have a meal.
Jake:做蛋糕差不多对就结了
Jake: Making the cake is almost done, then we're good.
Tasha: 楼上装饰好了你要不要看看
Tasha: The decorations upstairs are done, do you want to take a look?
Tasha: 好麻的麻麻酱酱的味道
Tasha: The flavor is so numbing, like numbing sauce.
Jake:可以来准备开饭吧
Jake: We can get ready to eat now.
Tasha: 哇吃不下了累了
Tasha: Wow, I'm too full, I'm tired.
Tasha: 喝饮料
Tasha: Drink some beverage.
Tasha: 饮料
Tasha: Beverage.
Tasha: 杨梅复合汁喝吗
Tasha: Do you want some bayberry juice?
Tasha: 鲜牛奶没了
Tasha: We're out of fresh milk.
其他人：我要汽水
Others: I want soda.
Tasha: 汽水在楼上
Tasha: The soda is upstairs.
Tasha: 有可乐那你顺便去参观一下吧
Tasha: There's cola, you can check it out while you're up there.